[Music]
I'm resolving to actually listen to my
husband when he talks to me now I'm on
my phone and it just I don't even is
important I'm sorry okay my use to find
my treadmill oh I think a lot of people
on the fitness kick Jack first gotta
reintroduce myself
well we asked stars what their new
year's resolutions are and here's what
they told us as we say goodnight bye
everybody I just want to spend more time
with with the people that I love the
United Stated people it's yeah I don't
think I mean but you know I always do
better I think throughout whatever I
decide to do whenever I go on to do I
just wanna be happy last year I think my
resolution was to take more time off and
it seems I've worked more this year than
just like parlay that into next year my
new year's resolution one of them is to
say no more often let me get New Year's
resolution because I make resolutions
like every I turned 30 this year I think
I'm kind of made many resolutions on
that my personal advice is do a mini one
everyday so I do it in the morning I
write it the first thing and then at the
end of the day I score myself out of ten
got to keep yourself on us well I want
to be a better wife a better lover a
better mother a better individual I want
to give more I want to love harder just
be better
[Music]
you